i need a hundred a hundred and five
hundred
did you get what i needed wow these are
pretty which one is gonna make me feel
like less hostile blue oh
before we get started you got my money
what does this feel like
it's a little late if you don't give me
what i need then i have to do something
bad i don't want to do something bad do
you understand
i'm gonna get your money
surprise
your grandmother left these papers in
case of emergency
she didn't have a dimensional will did
she dear kazoo
there's no money there's however
a magical little girl your sister
all she's got now is you she can
understand everything you are saying to
her
and if you are happy press this one i am
sad very funny troublemaker
she sees the world in a completely
different way from us
we're about to have a pool party
[Music]
[Applause]
and how many days clean 30. we'll just
see about that won't we
you're on probation yeah
[Music]
i'm gonna help her just like she helps
me
and i'm actually learning how to laugh
because i love her
together